une dix neuvième visite du prince
charles au canada un voyage annonciateur
d'une nouvelle ère
le futur roi doit démontrer qu'il est de
100 ans et que la monarchie est toujours
pertinente aujourd'hui plus que jamais
nous avons besoin de l'esprit
d'initiative de la compassion et de
l'humanité des canadiens
le thème de la réconciliation avec les
autochtones s'est imposé l'un des
premiers arrêts le jardin du coeur
consacré à la mémoire des victimes des
pensionnats autochtones
oui et non
avant l'arrivée du prince et de la
duchesse des leaders autochtones ont
réclamé des excuses ou des compensations
de la part de la famille royale au
minimum la tournée a le mérite de
braquer les projecteurs sur les enjeux
autochtones croit ce représentant inouk
de granby
à ses yeux beaucoup de mal a été fait au
nom de la couronne et maintenant ils
espèrent beaucoup de bien pas d' excuses
du prince charles mais une courte
déclaration
la réconciliation est un engagement à
long terme vers la guérison at il plaidé
s'il doit composer avec le passé le
prince charles tente aussi de démontrer
qu'ils regardent vers l'avenir la cause
des changements climatiques qui lui est
chère sera au coeur de sa visite mais
dans ces décors de carte postale sa
mission en est aussi une de relations
publiques dans une monarchie en pleine
transition il est aussi au canada en
fonction de la future roi du canada donc
c'est très important pour lui d'être vu
au canada par les canadiens une grande
séduction à coups de mises en scène
gourmande allant de la crème glacée
locales
à la pinte de bière
une opération où tout semble calculé
pour tenter de rapprocher la monarchie
des gens ordinaires